i still have a feeling that there would
be people who are like anti-vaccine even
if it was fda approved
i'd be like they'd be like why is the
government mandating that do this thing
even though that they mandate that you
do get vaccines for other things like
your kids get vaccinated for school etc
but i think that the fact that there is
like a little bit of an insecurity of
the efficacy of the vaccine
i i completely understand like not
wanting to be forced to take something
that the government isn't even sure is
totally good
like the government will say flayed out
flat out it's not fda approved yet
you're right right they'll just say that
flat out but they're also saying
we want you to take it
that's tricky yeah
who do we trust do we trust you or you
yeah like which you do we trust yeah do
we address the you that says it's not
ready
yeah for approval that doesn't mean it's
not ready to take i've taken it but
it's not ready for approval or do we
test to you that says hey we need all of
you to take it what do you guys think
yeah i mean it's like tricky and i kind
of understand rogan's position where
it's like i i even understand not
wanting to do it if you're just mandated
to do it like i know a lot of people are
like yeah i want to get it but i don't
want to be forced to get it yep and
like to the dictatorship point like i
don't think america's ever going to be
that into a full-blown dictatorship but
also every operational dictatorship
didn't think they were gonna be in a
dictatorship you know what i mean like
it was a desperate people that were
polarized and like and then someone came
through and
became a dictator yeah but i mean like
this isn't like taking i just don't see
it as like a big
act of taking away our liberties by
them
like mandating for us to do something
that is going to help us in the long run
right and that's how it's always like
that's what's always proposed and then
they just see like oh is it only going
to be used for that so like
this is like kind of a similar thing
what else is going to be used for like
just give me an example so i can help in
terms of like bodily autonomy like oh
you have to do something else with your
body that is going to help the greater
good you have to get vaccinated for
everything else
i don't know necessarily like what the
specifics are but
i
i see where people are going and some
people have this insecurity in this
anxiety and i'm sure there's a part i'm
not sure but i imagine there's a part of
rogan who's like a lot of people are
afraid to say this publicly
but they feel it
you know and i'm sure he has friends in
the science community that are like hey
i'd like to say this but i'm afraid of
saying this so he's like i'm going to go
out there and i'm going to say this
thing and i'm going to express the fears
that people have and i think that he's
done that a lot not just with vaccines
but he's done that with other things
obviously you know
i'm i'm very grateful but he's done it
for you know woke culture pc [ __ ] like
he's willing to push back so this is a
hot button topic right now with the
vaccines everything's going back to
vaccines so no matter how much sauce or
no matter how much sauce he puts on
himself the media is going to put all
the flavor oh that's true right like 100
so and anyone in a public position
that's not just in favor of getting it
and like wanting to push back and
question this thing that's going to
obviously help a lot of people they're
going to use yeah yeah so one thing that
like someone brought up actually that
was an interesting point is that the
there's a bill that's now put out that
is basically going to try to use
smartphones to scan what's on your
screen to see if there's dangerous
images have you heard about this
so like effectively they're able to use
ai to detect like if there's criminal
images on your phone if there's child
porn on your phone things like that in
order to obviously protect people from
having criminal images on their phone
what if somebody airdrops some child
porn on my phone and so obviously they'd
be able to trace where it came from if
you intentionally tried to get it blah
blah blah and they'd be able to use the
ar blah blah blah
but
people are bringing this up where
they're like yeah it's obviously going
to help a lot of people but is that all
they're going to use it for are they
going to be able to look for other
things like
any sort of like
dissent against the government
and so i think people are using that as
an analogy with the vaccine thing where
they're like okay they're going to force
us to do this what else we're going to
be forced to do
as we learn like with the snowden [ __ ]
it's like they're already looking
through all our stuff and it's like this
is what they're going to afford sorry
just me personally it's like if you
don't got nothing to hide like go
through my [ __ ] like if you're doing it
yeah to save us or just because you're
[ __ ] nosy go through my [ __ ] i think
i think you trust the government to go
through your [ __ ]
it's not it doesn't hurt it's not about
that and i understand i understand his
position i understand the push back to
your position as well yeah but i guess
what i think everything comes down to us
is like you could just follow capitalism
as capitalism is going to dictate the
market every single time in america like
wherever the money is made
that's where people are going to go so
obviously they're looking at these
cities and they're going i need to get
reelected so people kind of not die
right at the same time
if the economy shits the bet i might not
get reelected so i need to make sure the
economy keeps going and people don't die
what is the easiest way to connect those
two dots vaccine
people don't die people can go out buy
[ __ ] work do whatever that makes the
most sense to me i think that's why that
they would want to use it yeah i think
that's i think that's where their
position but you could file capitalism
with this [ __ ] every single time man but
once you hand over that power to the
government he's never gonna get 10 years
from now you have some president in
charge that's crazy that's like oh we
can just use this yeah to get and i get
that point too but it's like the the
thing that's interesting is if enough
people start boycotting the mandatory
vaccine
capitalism will support that
right yes so right now the corporations
are going you have to be vaccinated to
come into our club
right to perform in our club these
comedy clubs are all saying mandatory
vaccine if enough people start going i'm
not gonna do that [ __ ] you're not gonna
tell me what i got to do and they
stopped going to the clubs you know
what's gonna happen
the club
that doesn't require mandatory vaccine
is gonna start succeeding and then all
those other clubs are gonna go actually
you don't need mandatory vaccine etc
it's not necessarily about the
life-saving it's about the money-saving
yeah of course that's true right the
likelihood of that happening though it's
less because already so many people got
vaccinated exactly across the 50s it's
almost like they knew that 50 of people
were gonna do it and now they're just
bullying the other 20. and the 50
percent don't give a [ __ ] about those 20
because they're like [ __ ] i'm
already vaccinated yeah i can't go fight
for your rights for them not to tell you
even if you were going to push back but
since you already got vaccine you're
like i don't care your struggle's not my
struggle no more yeah right so it's like
matter of fact why i'm like why why
don't you want to get back am i going to
get some cancer you go get some cancer
too
and they did it right at the tipping
point they knew exactly it was over 50
right and they knew that that was gonna
be the hardest amount yeah the first 50
is easy right because they're going to
be a bunch of people like us are like i
just want to do normal [ __ ] what i got
to do do normal [ __ ] yeah i put most
things in my body to do normal [ __ ]
insert gage joke but like but but with
the people that are gonna be a little
tricky they're like all right now we're
gonna force you yeah and i understand
why it would piss those people off the
most because they're the most don't
force me people yeah they're the people
who who saw it coming
right there's tons of these videos of
people like well first they're gonna say
please get it now they're gonna force us
and they're saying not allowed to do
anything there's a bunch of these like
videos going around like people who
predicted what would happen it's like
you knew it was gonna happen yeah you
know exactly what's gonna happen you
knew that you're the people who push
back against any kind of government
overreach and you knew it was gonna get
to a point where in order to get to the
vaccination numbers where they want them
they're gonna have to bully you yeah and
they're starting out bullying you by
saying you can't go to restaurants you
can't go to movie theaters you can't
party you can't do this [ __ ] and
eventually they might bully you on some
real like you got to stay in the house
yeah if you're not vaccinated you can't
leave
that could be crazy if it gets to that
point then i'll have a little bit of
pushback right now it just seems like yo
and then and then the people who are
worried about government tyranny are
going to say you waited too long you
weighed too long right what is it when
they came for the blah blah blah i said
nothing when they came for these people
i said nothing and when they came for
those people i said nothing and then
when they came for me there was no one
to help yeah yeah i get it i get that
yeah
so so i empathize with these people i
empathize with joe and what he's
standing for and i empathize with these
people that push back you know i mean
for a large uh
we do a lot of times you know i mean
like on this podcast we push back a lot
of you saying if i didn't already have
the vaccine i'd probably push it back
too but i got it right so [ __ ] y'all
it's really what it is
yeah but i also think it's worth putting
the caveats of like you know while i
might disagree with the vaccine on like
a governmental level i also think that
it's safe that it's effective that if
you haven't had cove you should
definitely get it like i think there
needs to be balance in the conversation
especially if you're taking like a
controversial side yeah i mean like i
think that goes with any controversial
issue if you're talking about like
jail or whatever like you got to be like
also this is [ __ ] up and it's balanced
yeah yeah
yeah i think that i think that'd be fair
i think that'd be fair it's tricky man
that's tricky [ __ ] just need
some [ __ ] to talk about these days
you